[Music]
we're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty this week and joining me
is author of unwanted advances sexual
paranoia comes to campus as well as a
professor in the Department of radio
television and film at Northwestern
University
Laura Kipnis welcome to the Rubin report
thank you hi hi I have had a roughly if
I had to add it all up a gajillion
requests to have you on okay so I feel
like we're gonna clean up a lot of stuff
here related let's try yeah
related to title 9 I did my little
direct message my preamble sort of
giving a vague explanation of title 9
mm-hmm you sort of got in the mix on
this thing when you wrote a piece in The
Chronicles of Higher Education in 2015
which I want to get to that and your
whole story related to all of that but
first I thought could you just give me a
basic explanation of what title nine is
and then how it changed during the Obama
administration okay I should start out
and say that it was never my goal in
life to become an expert on title nine
but as you might've said in the intro I
was brought up on title nine complaints
and at the time I had no idea what this
was you know I thought it had something
to do with women's sports so the brief
backstory is that in 2011 the Department
of Education under Obama expanded title
nine which had a covered gender equity
in higher education meaning like equal
funding for sports teams and that sort
of thing and they expanded it to include
sexual misconduct because the idea was
that you can't have gender equity if
students particularly women's students
are you know fearful for their safety or
are being assaulted you know or harassed
or that kind of thing so you know it's a
it's it's a good goal but they issued
these things called Dear Colleague
letters that were guidance to
institutions of higher learning that got
federal funding and threatened that if
the schools didn't comply with these
very big guidelines that their federal
funding could be withdrawn and you know
most schools get you know tons of their
funding from the government in research
grants and that kind of thing so all
campuses were required
title nine offices and officers and
implement these this guidance and it had
to do creating processes for sexual
misconduct complaints but also dictated
things like the standard of proof that
would have to be used in these
adjudications and the standard was
what's called preponderance of evidence
and that's a hugely controversial thing
because it basically means is 50/50 plus
a feather and the process also has been
I mean as I learned having gone through
it behind closed doors so none of this
is out in the open or transparent and
it's you have more and more people
getting caught up in in these sort of
kangaroo court situations both
undergrads mostly male students who get
accused of having non-consensual sex
usually in drunken you know sexual
encounters that somebody later decides
was not consensual but also professors
increasingly so what happened was after
I got brought up on these complaints I
wrote a second article and I got brought
up for writing an essay about you know
the kind of increasing vulnerability of
students and it was called sexual
paranoid Const a khadeem yeah I think I
think maybe we should pause there
because you gave me a lot there so let's
just whittle away some of that right so
first off I think a certain amount of
people would would be listening to this
and thinking wait a minute how can a
university lower the expectation of what
evidence is to prove someone guilty of
something if it's supposed to be you're
innocent until proven guilty how can how
can a university have a expectation
that's lower than that how does that
even how does that even make sense I
mean what's the actual rationale there
well the rationale is that they're
following this federal guidance but you
know what happened what the federal
guidance seems to be in conflict with
the Constitution well so one of the
things I learned is you don't actually
have constitutional rights at a private
university so there's how this stuff is
handled differs between public
institutions and private schools and
private schools can do what they want so
they're in a more contractual relation
with students and you know a lot of the
information on this
only coming out because these cases are
going to civil court
so like students who've been accused and
think they've been railroaded are suing
the schools and that's how we learn
what's going on otherwise nobody would
know
so in effect these these edicts come
through from the administration it's on
you know now the the burden of evidence
is suddenly on the accused in a bizarre
way and it really never bubbled up until
some of the men in this case started
taking civil action because they were
either falsely accused or they felt that
they were false the accuser wanted to
fight yeah
or there are no standards of evidence
and so that was the kind of thing I
learned from going through the process
so I was accused of say creating a
hostile environment and I said to the
title 9 investigators what how do you
know I mean it's a or I was creating a
chilling effect on the student body and
I should we should explain that those so
your your 2015 article let's just
explain what that was and how it got you
a doubt water before every okay I'm
jumping for it I wrote an article called
sexual paranoia strikes a khadeem for
the Chronicle of Higher Education
because they asked me to write something
about campus sexual politics because I
was known I guess have been known as
something of maybe a contrarian feminist
and I'm written about sexual politics a
lot so I said okay and I kind of thought
nobody read the Chronicle of Higher
Education you know and so I've wrote in
a kind of ironic maybe you know I had
some fun with it
and I do lean toward irony and so first
there was a protest march on campus by
students carrying mattresses and pillows
you know like a reference to the
Columbia student accusing me of
fostering or supporting rape culture I
guess and then I was found out I was
brought up on these title non complaints
but so I never found out precisely what
I was charged with because there isn't
such a thing as due process in these
situations right so to be clear you
write this piece and as you're saying it
was kind of tongue-in-cheek but with the
expertise that you have he's serious but
with an ironic tone I would say yeah
yeah so you write this piece
and then you're brought up on these
charges but what does you writing this
piece have to do with anything how does
that yeah become within the jurisdiction
of title 9 well it should not have been
and so it is a question mark why the
university allowed the case to go
forward because there is some sort of
provision in the New York Holly Blair
order that says nothing here should be
construed to impinge on freedom of
speech or academic freedom but
nevertheless I mean what does happen
what's happened is what you would call
mission creep in these situations where
the code has been stretched to include
such things as writing an essay and as I
later found out I mean all sorts of kind
of micro behaviors that somebody might
take offence at so in my case I had
written a couple of paragraphs about a
another professor on the campus so I
didn't know but it was public
information that he'd been accused of
sexual misconduct so I made reference to
that case so I was accused of
retaliating which is a big thing in
title 9 you cannot mostly people cannot
speak about the charges against them
because if they speak about them they
might be brought up on more complaints
for retaliating so I was charged with
retaliation even though I wasn't the
person who'd been involved in the sexual
misconduct do it right and to be clear
so the person that was accused of this
who was a colleague of yours although
you did not know him he was accused of
of having relations with a student but
consensual if I'm not mistaken there
were two um there were two sets of
complaints and one was that he'd gone
out drinking with a student one night
and they ended up sleeping in this same
bed but they didn't have sex there's no
indication that they've had sex but he
was accused of possibly having come onto
her he bought her drinks and then there
was a second situation which I actually
did not write about where he'd had a
relationship with a student
so I wrote about seven or eight words
about that second relationship and that
was I think the basis of the complaints
that I'd made reference to this
situation that that in effect they felt
you were defending him correct
I suppose so you know I can't
say what anybody thought or felt really
right I guess I guess you can but I
think I think we can surmise that that's
what they thought yeah that you know
your feelings on on that specific matter
outside of title nine really is that
these are if they're consenting adults
whether he's a professor and she's a
student that you're okay with that
basically right um I in the first essay
I was somewhat mocking these new
regulations that govern professor
student dating the prohibited at
particularly in the case of undergrads
it was sort of okay if you're a grad
student
but frowned on and when I was one of the
things I was saying was that you know
you can look around any campus on the
country who can barely throw a stone
without hitting a couple a married
couple often with children that started
out as a professor students situation
and it's widely known in academia that
you know some percentage of your
colleagues are married to former
students so it seemed a bit hypocritical
to suddenly enact these codes that would
regard those situations as like close to
some sort of credit predators so I you
know I felt that the professorial was
almost being regarded as as predators in
waiting and that you know dating was was
was ruled out and you know I don't want
to sound like some old geezer and but
when I went to school back in the good
old days you know I think we did all
sorts of stuff we partied and drank with
professors it was no big deal people
were sleeping with professors all over
the place so the this new climate of
regulation was something I wanted to
write about from a somewhat skeptical
vantage point right so so in your mind
it really was about the regulation that
they were putting on not you weren't
specifically defending or not defending
the actions of this guy which i think is
sort of where it got turned a little bit
yeah yeah so I think that's interesting
I mean I the version of feminism that I
would subscribe to would see this
climate of regulation is not in the
spirit of feminism and I think I've used
the term feminist paternalism but I will
say what happened was that or maybe
we'll get to this I mean I ended up
learning more about the situation with
this professor and writing more about it
in this book so there's a couple of
chapters about these two cases against
the professor who I do a close reading
of the title 9 reports which I ended up
having access to and so that was very
informative all right so we will get to
that for sure
I think that'll that'll sort of bring
this all together ok but okay so now
you're brought up on these charges
mm-hmm what was that like for you I mean
literally you you're you're a professor
and an author yeah wrote an article yeah
yeah you're using words and now you're
brought up on charges from the
government yeah well for my institution
and but you know it's right from yours
yeah I mean I was very much in the dark
you know I knew nothing about title 9
and they send you like a letter with all
these links to various and you know
informational websites and every website
has more links and more links and you
know it's like a rabbit hole of
hyperlinks that you learn nothing from
like I do not learn how I could be
charged with retaliation for writing
about someone else's situation so it's
very mystifying the the procedures and
what I've learned in these cases when
you're accused of something for the most
part you don't find out what you're
accused of you don't know what the
evidence is you often don't know who the
accusers are in my case so I the the
University hired a team of outside
investigators lawyers from another city
who flew in to conduct an investigation
they would not give me the charges in
writing we I did finally learn who the
accusers were we had a Skype session
prior to me meeting with them but so
some of the procedures are very baffling
like why won't they give you the
complaints in writing how could that
possibly be legal I mean I get the sort
of kangaroo court portion of this and
how this is all done outside of our
legal system makes to me it makes no
sense whatsoever yeah but when you're
talking to these people and then there's
lawyers coming in from a de stainless
what are they talking to you about if
they are not telling you what you're
charged they ask a lot of fishing
expeditions sort of questions and as I
later talk to more people who've been
through these procedures that's the mo
is the fishing expedition question and
then
things that you say particularly if
you're a male professor charged with
some kind of potential misconduct
anything you say can lead to another
avenue of Investigation and so people
enter these situations they don't know
what their rights are you know so like
when the the investigators said to me
that I could not record the session you
don't know where these edicts are coming
from you just know somebody who seems to
be an authority is is telling you what
you can and can't do as I say you don't
know what your rights are and you don't
know what the consequences will be if
you don't go along with it and it is the
when this is happening is the entire
administration just falling into line I
mean is there anyone at the
administration that was like you know
Laura something seems wrong here or you
need a lawyer or we should have someone
defending you or sitting with you or
you're not something you or anything
yeah no you're not alone I think every
school makes their own procedures up in
my case you are not allowed to have a
lawyer in the session with you when I
met with the investigators I could not
have a lawyer there I did consult with a
lawyer on the phone before this but I
didn't want to spend a lot of money on
this you know how it's a bit of a
cheapskate but you know I will even if
you had all the money in the world it
would still be absurd professors are
spending tens of thousands of dollars
when you know accused of something like
having improper eye contact I mean some
of the charges are so out there but I've
talked to people who have I mean just
spent vast amounts of money consulting
with lawyers but it because of course
now there's a huge industry legal
industry and defending people caught in
these situations you know it's a huge
growth industry right okay so how did
your case get to pollution how did it
how did it wrap itself up
well it went on for 72 days I met with
these people who'd flown in the
investigators for three hours or so I
was allowed to have a support person in
the room with me and I asked the guy who
is the head of the Faculty Senate at the
time to be my support person
was not good because for him because he
later got brought up until 9:00
complaints himself for speaking out at
the Faculty Senate because he thought
that you know what it happened was a
violation of academic freedom and then
through that so he sits there with you
then defends you in another form and
then he gets brought up on yes did I get
ya fully badly that is right
but what you asked before about the
administration I mean I didn't know who
didn't know or who didn't know I was
told to keep this stuff confidential so
um it would it was just very unclear to
me what position I was in when I got
this letter about the charges yeah and
then not only that but then you have a
colleague offering counsel and then he
so the the chill effect around this
thing it's like why would anyone put
their butt on the line to defend you of
an free speech or defended a professor's
ability to teach the way they want if
they know that they're gonna be the next
one because the preponderance of
evidence is so low that they're gonna be
the next one cause see in my situation I
did not feel like my job was at risk I
didn't have enough paranoia about the
situation to think that my university
would actually fire me for writing an
essay I thought that that would be look
very bad for them so I felt somewhat I
didn't know what the outcome was going
to be but I didn't think it was going to
be that I would lose my job whereas if I
was a guy a male professor you know or a
student for sure but a male professor
accused of something that veered more
toward sexual misconduct I would be far
more I would have been far more worried
in this situation and I should just say
that like male professors in teaching
situations that involve more personal
contact with students like said dance
instructor or drama people or even music
where you might touch a student those
people are hugely at risk and I've heard
about so many cases like that where
something that once would have seemed
innocuous is now being charged as sexual
misconduct or creating a hostile
environment per student putting the
legal part of this aside for a second
what do you think this is doing to the
professor's so I get it if you're
talking about a dance
or an art teacher that may touch
somebody as they lean over or whatever
it is but from those people all the way
to just the regular professor that might
fear that if there's a student that
comes into their office and they say
something or only or as you said looks
at them really what do you think this is
actually doing to academia in general
right now I think the word is starting
to get out that professors are really at
risk of losing their jobs if there's any
kind of controversy with a student and
people may not know that something like
half the province all right now is not
tenured meaning you know or tenure
Stream meaning there's no job security
about half of professors now are kind of
contract employees this is it's the
casualisation of academic labor no I
didn't know that so you mean not even on
the track yeah yeah no they're hired
astad junks or instructors on renewable
contracts sometimes one-year contracts
and those people if they get caught in a
situation where student says that
professors said something in a class
that makes them uncomfortable those
people are out even if they're found not
guilty they are likely not going to be
renewed or if I there was a case just
recently there's a school of the Chicago
Art Institute with a guy was an art
history professor whose students accused
him of some students accused him of like
a textbook that he used they thought was
racist and it was a book about comic
book history and the history of that
period is of you know about like racial
imagery so it was a book that was
discussed that discussing racism in the
history of comics incredible so you know
there's such a professional of getting
caught in these situations that they're
very becoming very self censoring not
teaching controversial subjects being
very very careful about interactions
with students and I think also more and
more male professors are really shying
away from working closely with female
students because the numbers of
complaints about situations like that
have risen and I should just say look I
have said I believe any professor
that harasses a student that is in some
proposes some quid pro quo arrangement
like you know a [ __ ] for a grade I
mean those people should be fired I you
know they should be out there should be
no toleration for that well it's this
sense of a student feeling uncomfortable
in class about something somebody has
said those sorts of cases I think are
really just growing incredibly right and
at the same time just lowering the
burden of proof in general yeah also
just a horrific yeah precedent to say
yeah and because all this happens behind
closed doors there's no oversight and I
think a lot of people in the title nine
field now have gotten a bit on the how
inflated with a sense of power because
there are no there are no checks and
balances there's no oversight and so
they are enlarging their sense of what
sexual misconduct is onaconda capricious
ad hoc basis you know so it's very much
up to individual title nine officers or
in the case of undergrads like student
deans to decide what comprises an
offense and so I don't think that
there's more sexual misconduct and going
on I think what's defined as sexual
misconduct is just like exponentially
increasing yeah and that's what I want
people to understand if they take away
anything from this is that this system
created a secondary legal system in
effect yeah I mean that is simply not
how the United States operates it is and
people don't know this again I mean I
feel like in my book I sort of was
breaking news about the extent of this
because until it goes to civil cases
there's just no knowledge about what's
going on and it sounds like it would be
almost impossible to get that knowledge
out yeah because of the ridiculous
system where it seems like nobody's
accountable and you're not allowed to
talk to people you don't know what
you've been brought up on how do you get
this information out yeah and and not
every professor is gonna be as forward
as you and okay with still saying what
they think and coming on shows like this
and talking about it and all that yeah I
think only two professors
for other than myself have gone public
about cases against them because people
are terrified of speaking out and in
fact are threatened that if they speak
out they'll be charged with retaliation
and just in terms of title 9 generally
there's no aggregated you know set of
data about these cases I think we have
no knowledge of how many cases are what
the content of them is except for the
cases that have gone to civil court or
settlements paid by insurers there's
some data about the cases by insurance
companies
that's fascinating so you don't even
know how many not only how many cases
there are but how many other people
might be in your circumstance so not
people that have been accused of
anything in terms of doing an action or
having an inappropriate relationship
with a student or any of that there
could be literally five hundred other
people like you that just wrote
something in a vague defense of a
faculty member or of a take down of
title 9 that could be in your situation
and you just simply have no idea it's
incredible well so I think that I mean i
weirdly have become a kind of data
central by the virtue of people emailing
me about their cases so I mean I have an
email inbox file of cases that I don't
think there is other information about
and I don't exactly and I included some
of them and unwanted advances I have a
chapter called [ __ ] confidentiality or
their little Asterix they are where I
try to anonymize is that how you say it
um but going to as no as much detail as
I can about some of the bizarre cases
people have written to me about because
after I did go public about my case so
much if I said you know I just got all
of these emails from people about their
cases and I just wouldn't say that what
when I got this email saying I was
brought up on the these complaints I had
no idea if there were other professors
who've been charged over an article I
didn't know if this was a test case
where you know it would expand the
boundaries of title 9 so I was just in
the dark and I didn't know who to talk
to or to ask
it's so interesting to me because I've
had a series of guests on this show that
have been in similar situations either
in academia or elsewhere
people that have been put in situations
where they suddenly have to step into
sort of a new light brett Weinstein who
I'm sure you're familiar with from
Evergreen State and yeah Jordan Peterson
up in Canada dealing with this even
James d'amour from google I mean just
people that are just saying what they
think and then suddenly are thrust into
the spotlight in a different way so
shifting a little bit so then when when
Betsy DeVos last month basically said
we're gonna we're gonna turn back these
Obama era regulations you must have
found this quite rewarding or
vindicating or what's another adjective
I should use get afflicted over you can
say well not I mean you know I'm
conflicted in that I am NOT a person who
wants to have anything positive to say
about the Trump administration I mean I
you know don't want anything to do with
these people but I did think to vote was
doing what anybody with you know would
do in that situation which was to turn
back what had happened under the Obama
guidelines I'm not sure it's gonna make
any difference on campus I mean there's
been many many you know presidents tell
9 officers people in positions of power
have already said nothing is going to
change on our campus to reassure the the
title 9 activist that's actually crazy
though so the government you know I'm
not for all of these edicts that only
the executive branch makes but in effect
and that's what Obama did now Trump
reverses them ok yeah but you're saying
that the schools now because it's sort
of like a hostage situation where they
can't you know if they've made it sound
like this is the way it's supposed to be
and this is what's right they can't kind
of backtrack on it so they're gonna keep
in place basically is what you're saying
well I think here in California I'm
pretty sure Janet Napolitano is the
Chancellor president of the UC system
has announced that wow I didn't know
that yeah that's incredible yeah yeah to
show that they're on the right side of
things so I don't know one of the things
that's happened is that the there's been
this incredible bloating of the
administrative levels layers in
universities and these people are
running the place and there is such a
vast infrastructure that's been put in
place you can't just dismantle that
overnight so I think part of the mission
creep of all of this is that there's um
there are so many people whose jobs it
is to weed out misconduct and and
prosecuted to adjudicate it that that's
not going away you know so so I'm not
optimistic that the Devoe's guidelines
even though they are saying they're
gonna have this advice and consent or
advice and notice whatever it is period
that didn't happen with Obama under the
Obama administration they're trying to
do it more procedurally this time around
but in any case I don't see that it's
gonna filter down to the campus level
yeah that's incredible so how how could
it I mean if you had if you were in
charge right now if you were you know if
you had DeVoss Azir or Trump's here or
whatever it is what would you tell them
that actually needs to be done if this
if just removing these additions isn't
nothing I actually think that I don't
maybe a cynic that what's going to
happen is it more and more cases go to
civil court and will be decided against
the universities and that the general
counsel's office in the universities are
going to start overseeing what's
happening more than they are so it's
civil court judges that are looking at
these cases and saying are you kidding
can I just briefly talk about a case
that's a really interesting one that
came out of Brandeis because what was
interesting I mean most of these
situations at the undergrad level are
heterosexual but this was two guys and
two guys who are in a relationship and
then broke up and sort of six months
later one of the guys said that the
other guy had kissed him while he was
sleeping and that that was
non-consensual sex because he hadn't
consented to be kissed while he was
sleeping
so Brandeis appointed some sort of
special examiner this was a title nine
charge and the special examiner said yes
the kisser was guilty of non-consensual
sex because the other person hadn't
consented they kicked him out of school
so these are the kinds of cases that are
won
you know timeout mission creep or
overreach so the students sued the sued
Brandeis and you know you have to have a
lot of money to sue a university it cost
something like a 100 grand and up to a
million dollars if a case goes to trial
so this went to a judge and the judge
said you know are you kidding your this
is what you're calling sexual assault
and found against you know the against
Brandeis that may be getting some of the
the details wrong whether it was simply
dismissed or there was a judgment
against Brandeis but so it's the judges
that I think are going to be creating
that level of oversight and turning back
these cases and I think that might
filter down particularly as schools are
trying to pay out settlements to accuse
students yeah that's incredible because
for me personally I'm not someone that
would want it you know I think we have
way too much over litigation here but in
effect what you're saying is the only
way to really combat this is you need
students who've been improperly accused
that have the resources to start
bringing lawsuits because eventually the
schools will realize we can't sustain
this where we're taking so many cases
that actually don't hold without water
and we can't keep doing this and
professors as well and I think there are
a few I've heard about some cases that
prefer professors who've been dismissed
are suing universities too but they
haven't got has gotten as much attention
so I do think this is gonna be played
out in the courts for quite some time so
is there a piece of this that's sort of
obvious that I'm missing here how does
this not get to Criminal Court if there
was a case where it really involved not
just a kiss in the sleeping but if there
was a case that really involved rape or
yeah or being drugged or any of that how
is that not automatically a criminal
offense how does that even stay within
the jurisdiction of this yes doesn't
even make sense to me well you know one
of the reasons that these guidelines and
these processes moved to campus is that
at the the legal level you know District
Attorney's weren't taking these cases to
trial because in a lot of these
situations there isn't evidence the
person the accuser comes forward much
later you know so the either on an
evidence level or whatever don't rise to
the legal level so they were prosecuted
on campus because you know there was a
lag or gap in in you know the legal
systems dealing with sexual assault so I
understand that or it would take you
know years for a case to go forward so
part of the issue was to have a process
in place that would rectify what wasn't
happening off campus to get these
students if there were aggressive you
know usually male undergrads you know
particularly serial offenders you know
get them off campus so this was some of
the reasons that it wasn't handled at
the criminal level
[Music]
you